we're living now in the tick
tockification of social media so it's
not just Tick Tock that can go viral in
the next year Facebook Instagram
Snapchat YouTube shorts all of them are
going to benefit you for putting out
good content and it will go viral what
that means is we have something called
brand formants at vaynermedia something
you do organically emotionally hits with
people and then you take that same piece
of content and you slightly tweak it to
make it performance you add the price
you change the copy you change the way
the video ends and have it throw a right
hook to send them to a store a bar your
website with iOS 14.5 changing the world
and we don't have the retargeting
capabilities that made everybody in DTC
very math based we're gonna have to go
into creative but taking advantage of
the algorithms of the modern social
networks we will know what people are
interested in if we make a commitment to
organic social and when we have virality
we turn those into the ads